[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission nous
allons bientôt baisser le le rideau de
2023 et bien c'est l'occasion de revenir
sur quelquesuns des événements qui ont
marqué cette année et puis on essaa
aussi de se projeter sur quelquesuns des
des événements qui vont marquer l'année
qui vient c'est-à-dire l'année 2024 avec
Joséphine Colman SuperG bonjour bonjour
vous êtes la mère de plaisir vous êtes
vice-présidente de saint-cantan
d'iveline et vice-présidente aussi du
conseil départemental en charge
notamment de la culture euh et merci
d'être avec nous parce qu'on va parler
notamment bah d'un événement qui vous a
beaucoup marqué euh ce sont les émeutes
qui ont eu lieu à la fin du mois de juin
et au mois de juillet
Véronique gérô bonjour bonjour Patrice
bonjour à tous vous êtes maître de
conférence science
économique g s de gestion pardon à
l'université de de
saclé il y a il y a aussi ai beaucoup de
problèmes économique qui sont posé cette
année et dont on ne sait pas je parle P
par exemple l'inflation s' vont
continuer ou
pas jeoff me bonjour bonjour Patrice
vous êtes avocat au barreau de versaill
absolument et Jean-Charles Jo bonjour
bonjour vous êtes éditeur on dira
peut-être un mot à la fin de l'émission
de la bête des ves une de de vos
dernières publications qui qui éta écrit
notamment par Daniel ti Daniel ti était
la première femme commissaire de police
commissaire divisionnaire divisionnaire
prière femme commissaire divisionnaire
pris Duqu les orfèvres et absolument et
là oui c'est sur la bête de volon on on
en par un pe tout à l'heure à euh alors
on va revenir sur un certain nombre
d'événements de l'année mais bah le
dernier de ces événements c'est quand
même la loi qui vient d'être votée la
loi la loi immigration et Joséphine
colvberg justement c'est je voudrais
bien avoir votre point de vue alors il y
a deux façons he d'aborder cette loi il
y a la gauche qui dit c'est une honte
c'est une trahison le rassemblement
national qui dit c'est notre victoire
idéologique et puis au milieu Emmanuel
Macron qui s'est exprimé hier dit ben
non c'est d en même temps on favorise
l'immigration du travail mais on est
plus sévère face au par exemple à la
délinquance des immigrés des UTF vous
qui êtes dans une mer d'une ville où il
y a l'immigration part d'immigration
d'une part est-ce que un texte à votre
avis était nécessaire est-ce qu'il y a
des des mesures qu'il faut prendre et et
quel est un peu le le sentiment de votre
population si si vousouz l'exprimer bon
que qu'il ait besoin de d'un texte et
des réglementations certainement je
pense que ça c'était attendu après la
méthode ne m'a pas vraiment convaincu on
va dire hein les uns et les autres on
s'est rendu compte que on est un petit
peu dans le mode de fonctionnement de
notre président c'est-à-dire on sait pas
très bien où on va aujourd'hui il y a
plus tellement ni de droite ni de gauche
donc c'est c'est un espèce de de
de une macédoine un peu compliqué on a
du mal à comprendre pour revenir à la à
la population plaisiroise moi j'ai
effectivement un quartier en politique
de la ville avec avec 40 etthnies
différentes donc aujourd'hui oui
effectivement il y a des inquiétudes
hein par rapport à à certaines ch qui
sont en train de se mettre en place et
qui vont certainement perturber le
quotidien des personnes qui sont là
puisquon a des personnes qui sont tout à
fait dans la réglementation il y en a
d'autres qui ne le sont pas et c'est
vrai qu'il y a des des fortes
inquiétudes pour le moment j'ai pas de
retour je dirais direct de personnes qui
viennent me voir en me disant madame le
Maire qu'est-ce qui va se passer est-ce
que je vais être remis à la frontière
j'ai pas ça mais c'est à nous moi et
puis les élus de faire la démarche
auprès d'eux pour justement leur
expliquer les choses et puis peut-être
aussi les rassurer parce que que même si
on a besoin de je dirais de gérer ce ce
sujet-là il y a aussi quelque chose qui
est important c'est de c'est de voir que
des personnes sont déjà sur le
territoire et que il y a des personnes
je veux dire qui sont intégrées ou qui
commencent à s'intégrer donc il y a tout
ça à regarder c'est pas aussi binaire
que ça donc aujourd'hui même nous les
élus on a du mal à comprendre hein de ce
qui se passe c'est compliqué moi j'ai je
je suis assez je
dirais étonnée de ces accords de ces
désaccords de ces alliances de ces més
alliances qu'il y a eu je comprends plus
très bien l'ELR la gauche le Front
national chacun tire la couverture à soi
on est vraiment euh par le biais de
cette loi on est vraiment dans je dirais
dans ce mélange incompréhensible
aujourd'hui qui fait partie de cette
politique qui est la nôtre et qui est
tenue par le gouvernement moi je suis je
le dis hein euh c'est très très
compliqué en tant que citoyenne mais
aussi en tant qu'élu aujourd'hui et bien
de mettre en application et en
compréhension à la population ce qui se
passe c'est très très compliqué même
s'il y avait des choses à faire bien sûr
d'illeurs un problème très complexe
qu'on qu'on j'ai l'impression qu'on le
traite de manière très passionnelle en
France alors c'est souvent un problème
assez technique d'abord on a le droit de
savoir si on veut des immigrés lesquels
et c ça ça tout le monde est d'accord
là-dessus après c'est vrai que on en
fait un problème au fond il y a trois il
y a trois grandes tendances il y a la
tendance qui est celle du de dire il y a
le grand remplacement il y a un peu une
tendance libérale qui est de dire bah on
a besoin d'immigrés notamment pour faire
c'est c'est c'est ce que disent les
chefs d'entreprise et puis et puis il y
a il y a peut-être une autre vision plus
plus à gauche qui est dire il faut la
France est une terre d'accueil il faut
qu'elle reste une terre d'accueil mais
c'est trois trois visions très très
complexes à à à mener ensemble en fond
mais si on prenait ça d'un point de vue
économique ENF brutalement économique et
pas très respectueux dans la parole en
tout en tout cas je pense qu'il y a un
problème de stock et un problème de flux
donc le stock c'est le stock de la
population qui est déjà présente ah oui
c'est très économique voilà complètement
et après c'est le message que l'on
envoie à de potentiels flux et donc là
il y a déjà deux discours qui devraient
se ceinder et concernant la population
qui est présente il y a celle qui l' de
façon légale et puis celle qui l' de
façon non légale et sur ce point de vue
aussi on peut avoir des considérations
de d'équité face aux individus en
considérant que travaillant cotisant
donc droit a sur les les allocations non
contributive là effectivement il y a un
vrai débat mais le fait générateur
travaille me semble dans l'esprit de la
protection sociale au sens on l'entend
en France donc ça ne me choque pas de
dire enfin mon avis n'importe peu mais
en tant qu'économiste ça ne me choque
pas de dire il y a un fait générateur
évident donc il a quand même uneigation
l'esprit de la loi de favoriser
l'immigration de
travail de faire en sorte que le délai
soit moins long que pour ceux qui n'ont
pas ce fait générateur là et puis aussi
le le le message que l'on envoie et puis
a une autre une autre strate qu'il ne
faut pas oublier c'est celle de l'Europe
parce qu'en même temps et on est
toujours dans le même temps il y même
temps il y a un autre message qui est
envoyé sur l'asile et cetera plus les
une réglementation européenne qui vient
de sortir en même temps que la loi fr il
y a aussi le trait local certains
départements qui annoncent qui ne
respectent alors là je ne sais pas la
loi nous dira jusqu' bien est-ce que
c'est un effet d'annonce est-ce que
c'est possible mais qu' ne vont pas
respecter la loi il y a les médecins qui
considèrent aussi sur l'aide médicale
d'État mais là c'est pas c'est sortie de
la loi donc pour l'instant on y touche
pas pour mieux peut-être revenir plus
tard parce qu'il y a un vrai débat aussi
donc là il y a a y a et le problème
c'est qu'avec j'en terminerai là-dessus
avec une seule mesure on peut pas
atteindre autant d'objectifs c'est
impossible donc c'est c'est c'était très
prétentieux dès le départ de vouloir
donner une réponse à l'immigration avec
une seule une seule loi c'est peit pas
possible me semble je oui mon alors je
je je partage pas tout à fait votre avis
sur le fait qu'il fallait nécessairement
une loi ou en tout cas je ne suis pas
forcément convaincu sur les
l'aboutissement de de ce qui s'est passé
en réalité les deux grands thèmes de la
loi sont effectivement euh la question
de du travail comment est-ce qu'on
intègre cette cette immigration qui
travaille et également comment est-ce
qu'on renvoie des personnes chez elles
lorsqu'elles sont soit frappées d'une
qtf soit éventuellement lorsque un
tribunal ou une cour d'assise prononce
une interdiction définitive du
territoire or en réalité ce qu'on voit
lorsque on s'attarde un petit peu au
contenu de la loi qui peut en plus
évoluer puisqueelle va devoir être
passée au filtre du Conseil
constitutionnel et on ne sa pas a
probablement des des mesures il y a sans
doute des choses qui vont qui vont
disparaître et on voit quand même que
les choses ont été très imparfaitement
réalisées sur le plan de l'immigration
du travail il y a eu plusieurs quand
même mouture de ce fameux article 3 sur
la régularisation des travailleurs
quiici qui officie dans les métiers dit
en tension donc je je pense que
là-dessus les choses auraient sans doute
dû et enfin pu et dû être mieux faites
et également sur la question du renvoi
chez eux de ces personnes qui sont en
situation de clandestinité ou situation
de délinquence en réalité les
dispositions elles existaient déjà la
question elle était la question
préignante elle était plus de savoir
comment est-ce qu'on rend effectif oui
où les renvoyer ù les renvoyer quel pays
va les accepter est-ce que leurs pays
d'origine vont les accepter c'est ça la
vraie question c'est ça et je pense pas
sauf à ce que des choses m'est échappé
que la loi dans sa mouture actuelle
résolve ce problèmel h
mais vous n'avez pas dit que ça résolve
non non mais j'entends j'entends que
elle est pas parfaite et que euh c'est
c'est un mais il y a il y a aussi une
demande de l'opinion hein qui
qui complètement euh juste pour pour
évoquer le fait que les toutes les
personnes que j'ai que j'ai sur la ville
et puis tous les autres parce que j'ai
la chance d'avoir une ville très
diversifiée au niveau des quartiers et
il est clair que les les les le ressenti
est pas du tout le même d'un côté d'un
côté comme de l'autre hein et comme
comme vous disiez effectivement il y a
des gens qui attendaient quelque chose
qui n'est pas parfait évidemment et il y
a certainement d'autres choses à faire
et on s'en rendcre moi je voudrais
surtout qu'on n'oublie pas le côté
humain parce que c'est important quand
même de parler d'umain des hommes et des
femmes he c'est des hommes et des femmes
et des enfants moi je les je les croise
je les vois je suis avec eux comme la
plupart des élus je veux dire dans dans
les villes où on est confronté à à ça et
il y a un côté positif et humain qu'il
faut pas abandonner c'est vrai que quand
on parle de loi quand on parle tous les
discours qu'il a eu là on n'entendait
jamais parler d'humain de personne on
parlait uniquement de réglementation et
la loi et la droite et la ST et de FL
exactementyz vous
pvez pas de
problème on a parlé que de technique et
jamais du exactement et ça ça
Dér mais cette vision libérale qui est
de dire voilà on va on va régulariser
des des des des gens qui sont en
situation irrégulière parce qu'il
travaillent c'est il y a une critique
qui est de dire aussi mais peut-être que
vous pourriez aussi augmenter les
salaires il y aurait peut-être des
Français qui viendraient travailler à
leur place alors on peut aussi
dire compliquer un peu les règles de du
chômage et peut-être que beaucoup de
gens retourneraient au boulot aussi euh
donc bah oui non ça c'est quand même un
grand débat chômage qui devienne trappe
à pauvreté aujourd'hui et le système est
est mal conçu parce qu'on rincite pas on
n'incite pas à retrouver c'est are G
mais non non c'est pas une autre
question c'est vraiment li parce que
c'est pour ça que le patronat il se dit
on va pas prendre de fronts tous les
syndicats et tout le monde en parlant de
du chômage bah ok régularisons tous les
gens dont on a besoin
voàbéraleé même m même si du point de
vue des des immigrés qui travaillent on
peut la comprendre et ça peut faciliter
aussi leur vie enfin c'est assez complex
un espoir faut pas entretenir l'espoir
qu'on ne peut pas qu'on ne peut pas
soutenir enfin c'est nentreti pas de ce
qu' ne peut-être espéré c'est un peu ça
à partir du moment où ils sont sur le
territoire où ils ont un job où ils
donnent ils font ils sont ils sont parti
intégrante d'une économie on pourrait
quand même considérer qu'on a peut-être
un D vis-à-vis d'e après la réflexion
que que porte le patronat aujourd'hui
elle est un peu moi j'ai trouvé un peu
un peu particulière parce que le fait
d'annoncer qu'on aura besoin mais c'est
pas particulier au patronat français et
dans d'autres pays aussi on annonce déjà
et l'Italie est partic paradoxal aussi
on annonce des besoins à l'avenir à les
chances de 2050 ça se chiffre en en
milliers de de de de de besoins de
demandes et on ne tient pas compte de
l'environnement projeté parce que la
demande qu'on estime aujourd'hui elle
est avec les considérations
d'aujourd'hui sur des métiers qui
peut-être en 2050 n'existeront plus donc
si on pense qu'on va aller sur des
métiers des métiers qui sont en tenstion
sont pas les métiers avec avec des des
compétences extrêmes donc ce sont des
métiers à bas cût les bas salaires je
pense que là c'est un peu c'est un peu
de la décroissance et on fait un peu
machine arrière et annoncer qu'on va
avoir des besoins sur ces métiers rien
n'est sûr et c'est très dangereux me
semble-til d'utant qu'il y aura eu sans
doute aussi un grand débat sur la
classification à la catégorisation des
métié en tenstion quels sont les mété
tenstion qui rentrent sous l'ég de la
loi et comme dit Véronique c'est pas
métiers ention dans 10 ans ils seront
probablement plus les mêmes donc mais le
vrai débat au-delà de de la
régularisation de de
certains
immigrés sur des métiers en tenstion
c'est très bien mais faut pas pas
oublier le fait qu'il y a un un nombre
incroyable de gens en situation
irrégulière et que quand on en arrive à
dire que les gens en situation
irrégulière aurait des droits
inalienables et cetera je pense c'est
absolument incompréhensible pour la
population parce qu'on se dit mais où
est le droit où est la loi c'est-à-dire
que quelqu'un qui est en situation
irrégulière qui n'a priori donc pas le
droit de résider en France dit mais
alors il faudrait qu'il ait des aides il
faudrait qu'il ait ceci il faudrait
qu'il ait cela mais je veux dire c'est
dévastateur dans l'opinion les gens ne
comprennent pas mais alors oui c'est
comme comme on vous dit il y a que 5 %
des qtf qu'on peut qu'on peut envoyer
c'est vrai que quand ils commettent un
un un crime ou un délit l'opinion ne
peut enfin c'est très difficile de de
faire
comprendre même si techniquement c'est
très difficile et depuis 3 jours tout le
monde tout le monde s'assoit sur la loi
puisque là on dit bah oui il faut il
faut des lois des droits pour les gens
qui sont hors la loi bon ça c'est quand
même un concept assez assez étonnant et
maintenant on on a on a des départements
de gauche qui disent nous nous ne nous
n'obéirons pas à la loi et personne ne s
fuse contre ça que des élus disent là on
la respectera pas et ben ça ça pour dire
un truc ça passe crème et là j'ai pas
entendu land land ce matin dire c'est
étonnant non là tout va bien bah oui
c'est pas grave la loi on s'en
fout mais on pe on peut dire ça de la
gauche mais on pourriez dire ça de l'
rovquier qui qui je dis ça tout le monde
je dis ça de tous les gens qui ne
respectent pas la loi mais puisqu'on
donne des droits à des gens qui sont
censés ne pas en avoir B effectivement
c'est
vrai je ve dire vous avez raison de
souligner ce problème parce que c'est un
problème qui concerne la gauche la
droite peu importe c'est pas c'est pas
une question politique mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a une sorte de
désobéissance par rapport à l'état qu'on
voit de plus en
plus diff un dénit de démocratie totale
parce que là l'Assemblée nationale elle
a pas pris le pas pris le pouvoir par
les armes elle a bien été élu doncelle
pas montré l'exemple en plus ces
derniers
temps c'est peut-être aussi pour ça
qu' donc là il y a un vote et personne
ne respecte ça on s'en fout c'est pas
grave passons autre chose emble de la
sociétéin dans le quotidien je vous le
dis depuis quelques années on pensait
que pendant la covid effectivement il y
avait tout tout cet amalgame on était
les uns avec les autres en super
protection c'était très beau et je me
suis dit oh là là sortir de ça ça va
être pied ça va être formidable pas du
tout ça s'est tendu d'une façon
incroyable nous on le voit au niveau de
notre quotidien la population dont je
fais partie on devient très exigeant on
devient autoritaire c'est tout de suite
maintenant c'est sociétal je veux dire
il y a un vrai changement de la société
qui impacte automatiquement même les
élus leur mode de de de fonctionnement
je vous donne un exemple basique quand
vous montiez une liste électorale au
niveau d'une collectivité vous aviez le
maire et vous aviez les adjoints les
conseillers municipaux très bien en
général on était tous derrière le maire
on avait une feuille de route et cetera
jamais rarement au sein de je dirais de
la période où vous étiez là ben il y
avait des désistements des votes contre
ça n'existait pas on était comme un seul
ça n'existe plus ça n'existe plus oui il
y a des oui c'est aujourd'hui c'est
chacun pour soi chacun a raison chacun
et je l'évoqué tout à l'heure en dehors
de l'émission mais c'est vrai que même
la population aujourd'hui est comme ça
c'estàdire que quand vous concertez la
population vous discutez avec eux d'un
projet vous leur dites alors on fait
quoi on vous explique on échange oui
très bien on y va on vote là comme ça
avant de prendre la décision ah ben non
moi je vote pas je suis désolée je
prends pas de décision parce que je vais
pas voter pour ceux qui sont pas venus à
la Réunion je veux dire c'est très
caricatural mais c'est exactement pareil
de ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est exactement ça on est
dans une une bouilliie incroyable parler
de malaise démocratique mais c'est un
peu je crois que c'est exactement ça ENF
c'est un peu dû à notre président qui
qui avec cette niaiserie de démocratie
participative à chaque instant qui à
chaque fois qu'on peut qui peut créer
une commission thodule pour essayer de
de donner moins d'importance à à des de
véritables élus on va faire une
commission sur tous les sujets des
commissions des commissions des
commissions des commission parce que
c'est une sorte de réponse à ce malaise
démocratique aussi la cause c'est la
cause de de ce malaise c'est la cause de
ce malaise mais le malaise est cique
parce que François Olivier schisberg
dans son dernier ouvrage il parlait de
du tpmg tout pour ma gueule enfin pardon
de l'expression mais je crois que c'est
voilà c'est pas de nouveau c'est quelque
chose qui revient qui revient
régulièrement et le télétravail et le
fait de pouvoir commander à distance
tout faire à distance chez soi fait que
il y a une un rep sur soi qui est qui
est conséquent et contre lequel on aura
du mal à lutter et il y a les violences
contre les élus euh ou se multipe quand
même vous en avez vous l'avez vécu
doncoui oui j'en ai parlé au Congrès des
MRE puisqu'on m'a demandé de d'être
témoin où effectivement sur un conseil
municipal j'ai vu arriver une trentaine
de personnes
cagoulé tapant sur les vitres de la
salle du conseil où j'étais avec
quelques élus dont des femmes qui étaiit
blanches comme la table tellement elles
avaient peur et c'était c'était très
violent avec des gestes gorgement et
tout tout ça pour une loi enfin une loi
pardon une délibération qui était une
délibération de l'amélioration du
quartier en difficulté et parce que bah
il y a des personnes qui veulent pas que
les quartiers changent et y a des
personnes qui ont aucun intérêt
notamment les trafiquants ENF voilà pour
faut mais oui exactement il sont des
agitateurs ils ont pas du tout envie que
ça bouge un peu et qu'on aille voir un
peu ce qui se passe donc et donc cette
violence elle est c'est terrible vous
mettez quelques jours à vous en remettre
quand vous avez la police qui vous
accompagne chez vous qui fait le tour de
la maison pour voir si tout va bien
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui c'est mais alors encore une
fois je le répète de la même façon que
je disais tout à l'heure pensons à
l'humain ne caricaturont pas
c'est-à-dire que ces personnes qui sont
nes ne représentaient pas l'ensemble du
quartier mais ça existe voyez ce que je
veux dire mais bien sûr existe et c'est
vrai que cette remise en cause générale
de l'autorité quoi très viol même de
celle des profs là je lisais ce matin
dans le Journal il y a un élève qui a
fait boire du détergent à son à son prof
on a vu les l'histoir rcent qu'on parle
tout à l'heure mais on pe oui non mais
c'est enfin c'est pas reconcours voilà
c'est menace de mort contre enfin
reconcours dans un dans un lycée privé
lance de cassti c'est c'est incroyable
incroyable judiciirement il est clair
que l'année 2024 on en parlera sera sans
doute celle du
traitement massif de toutes ces
infractions des violences commises
contre les professeurs des violences
commises contre les élus de toutes les
violences contre les personnes qui
incarnent une forme d'autorité et qui
effectivement ont explosé je pense que
les cœur de la République vont être
extrêmement sensibilisés sur le fait que
maintenant il faut traiter de manière
approfondie et ferme sur le plan
judiciaire ces problématiques là qui
sont effectivement
inadmissibles il y a des a un texte
spécial d'ailleurs pour les élus il y a
un texte effectivement qui il y a
effectivement un texte qui va qui va
prochainement alors si ma mémoire est
exacte qui va être prochainement publié
et qui augmentera augment les PE les
sanctions lorsque euh des violents
l'autorité CIS contre les personnes
investies d'un mandat électif public ou
qui sont dépositaires de l'autorité
publique je suis ravi parce que j'ai
plutôt l'impression que de24 être
l'année de la création du droit au refus
d'obtempéré donc c'était vu que
maintenant ça paraît normal il il a de
tempérer bah le pauvre ah bah oui c'est
c'est c'est dommage bah oui je veux dire
c'est la liberté de chacun bon donc je
après c'est la responsabilité que c'est
celle des parents quand c'est quand
c'est pas un adulte est-ce que en
mettant en cause la responsabilité des
parents dont on sent que il y a il y a
enfin il y a un débat est-ce que ça va
changer les choses ou pas parce que
alors justement puisque vous
par justement c'était c'était c'était
notamment Éric duupti ministre de la
Justice qui avait parlé de la
responsabilité des des parents au moment
des émeutes et je voudrais qu'on qu'on
revienne sur cette question qui qui qui
a marqué 2023 et je vais commencer avec
vous parceque vous avez vécu moi je vous
m'avez envoyé un sms au moment des des
émeutes en me disant mais c'est c'est
terrible quoi ce qui se passe ils en
prennent aux écoles aux mairies euh on
sait pas ce qui va on sait pas ce qui va
se passer par en plein milieu des des de
ces émeutes on ne savait pas comment si
ça allait s'arrêter ou jusqu'où ça
allait aller quatre nuits quatre nuits
blanches quand même hein quatre nuits
blanches police pompiers police
municipale élu dans les voitures
banalisées pour faire le tour de la
ville pour protéger les bâtiments
publics quelque chose qui est sorti
comme comme ça je veux dire une
explosion inattendue euh très très très
perturbante parce que quand on sait les
investissements que tout le monde fait
dans dans dans les quartier auprès des
jeunes qui sont je dirais déscolarisés
ou ou qui ont vraiment des
problématiques familiales on n' pas
compris cette démarche là ce qui est
dramatique c'est que effectivement ils
se sont attaqués à tout ce qui était la
représentation de la République c'est ça
qui est qui est qui est dur de faire
brûler des écoles par exemple alors que
les petits frères les gens leurs voisins
sont dans ces écoles là on n pas très
bien compris même leur seul moyen de
sortir un peu leur condition si je peux
dire enfin si si l'ascenseur républicain
March alors après cela dit c'est vrai
que c'est le sentiment la première
analyse qui a été faite cétait en effet
ils se sont pris au au symbole de la
République il semblerait qu'au fond
c'était moins idéologique que ça quiil
sont surpris à ce qu'il connaissaient
oui au quartier enfin voilà parce que
c'est il faut dire que les émeutes enfin
les les les foutur d'meutes si je peux
dire venz c'était des habitants de de de
ces ville on venait pas d'une ville à
l'autre hein on les connaissait connaiss
oui vous les connaissiez bien sûr oui on
les connaissait pardon peut-être pas
lire ils ont pas vu qu' marqué école
c'est ça aussi le truc je pense que
c'est c'est c'est compliqué en en
réalité d'analyser d'un planri sur un
plan strictement sociologique les
événements qui se sont déroulés en
réalité c'est c'est c'est une colère qui
s'est exprimée de manière extrêmement
désordonnée comme la colère le fait bien
souvent
et alors que il y avait véritablement
une récrimination contre ce qui s'était
passé du fait de la mort de bon bah
effectivement ils ont fait un grand
amalgame police école maisirie en
réalité effectivement ce que vous disiez
Patrice tout ce qui incarne pour eux une
forme d'autorité donc une fois que ils
avaient il d'ailleurs deux étapes dans
cette révolte il y a il y a cette
première qui est en effet qu'on peut
analyser comme la suite d'une colère
même bon même si le le le fait qui qui
la provoque on peut en discuter mais et
puis il y a la deuxième qui est plus
pragmatique qui est celui des des des
des pillage enfin dans les très très
honnêtement quand on voit ce qui s'est
passé à montargie quand même très
éloigné de de de nantherre je pense que
les les émeutiers de montargie avait
assez peu à faire du petit an parti trop
vite pour reprendre les MOS de Mbappé
quoi enfin je veux dire non mais
honnêtement on sait très bien au 2005
aussi c'est alors c'est différent mais
ça vient aussi ça vient aussi voilà de
la mor c'est c'est un prétexte c'est un
prétexte il se il se moquait
complètement un prétexte évident mais
enfin c'est vrai qu'il y a eu C ces deux
étapes assez différente avec une chose
différente par rapport à 2005 qui est
l'importance des réseaux
sociaux c'est pour ça quand vous disiez
pas organisé si oui c'était organisé il
y avait il y avait des même des des gens
qui étaient habillés pareil et C
c'éitan ou c'était très organisé c'est
ça qui TR subit certes mais très
organisé parce qu'ils le sont déjà par
le B des réseaux ils sont organis puis
parce qu'ils sont extrêmement
manipulables très facilement c'est c'est
ça aussi le problème c'est vrai qu'il y
avait pas vraiment de de relation avec
le le jeune qui avait été qui avait été
tué parce que quand la police a
interrogé certains de ces jeunes parce
que bon bien sûr il y a eu quelques
arrestation et bien il savait même pas
de quoi il s'ag il y en a qui ne
connaissaient même pas son nom son
prénom C en de temp comme vous le disiez
Patrice et il y a une analyse
socio-territoriale qui a été fait par
des gens de science
poar oui et on bien étap et pu effetu
qui est très
inérrespond à peu près au gilets jaunes
au vill V
où c'est les territoires et c'est ils
ont noté aussi des corrélations alors
corrélation n'est pas raison mais il a
une corrélation sur 555 villes avec les
la densité de qpv quartier prioritaire
la politique de la ville où on voit que
il y a se fois plus de chance d'meutes
quand il y a un ou plusieurs quartiers
dans la ville que lorsqu'il n'y en a pas
et il y a aussi un lien avec avec le le
côté défavorisé au sens où les écoles
défavorisées sont des lieux où
véritablement là il y a une une
explosion de la violence ce qui était
pas le casilleurs en terme de de je dire
en comparaison pas en terme absolu mais
en terme de comparaison donc il y il y a
vraiment une une réflexion là aussi
qu'on pourrait produire oui il y a aussi
peut-être une réflexion sur en effet le
sentiment de discrimination qui qui qui
peut exister de de de de rapports
compliqué avec la police ENF il y a
aussi des des problèmes qui qui peuvent
exister abment mais mais il y a aussi la
dans cette
population vraiment enfin au-delà de
l'anarchie et
cetera un certain sentiment d'impunité
parce qu'après tout tout ils savent tous
très bien qu' n'y aura rien de très
grave quand on voit le les condamnations
qui sont tombées dire c'est pas la
surpopulation la surpopulation carcérale
n'est pas du aux émeutes de qui viennent
de se passer ça c'est sûr
donc j'ai brûlé une prison c'est pas
graveis un petit peu
ou je il vaut mieux toujours je me
permets alors je je et alors que vous
utilisez depuis tout à l'heure des
termes de Jun et c'est peut-être ça le
vrai apport de 2023 c'est que
Jean-Charles utilise notamment sa passe
crème alors je suis pas certain que
concernant les les émeutes sur le plan
de la justice ça soit passé crème
effectivement alors en fonction des
implications et des casiers enfin des
antécédents judiciaires ou pas c'est
comme ça que la justice effectivement
détermine la gravité de la sanction
qu'elle prononce ceux qui avaient ses
profils avoir pas d'antécédent et une
participation relativement minime j'ai
pas dit pas grave mais j'ai dit
relativement minime les sanctions
effectivement n'étaient pas des peines
d'incarcération bon ceux qui étaient
réitérants ou récidivants ils ont eu des
peines lourdes qui ont été prononcé et
ils ont été incarcérés hein qu'est-ce
que pouvez expliciter un peu le le
participation relativement minime he
c'est quoi c'est juste un cocktail les
suiveurs il y a toujours les suiveurs et
non non mais c'est trop facile
facile non non mais il faut quand même
on a le droit quand même sans être
polémique d'envisager que la personne
qui est là et qui participe à un
groupement ne doit pas être sanctionné
de la même façon que celui vous le
disiez a pris un cocktail monotophe et
l' lancé sur les policiers mais c'est
pour ça je vous demandis ce que c qu'une
participation
min a pe ou les gens qui sont là qui
sont arrê aussi la participation à un
groupe la participation et en fait il y
a deux infractions il y a la
participation à un groupement et il y a
la violence et à nouveau je pense qu'il
faut faire une vraie différence
d'ailleurs le législateur le fait sur le
plan des pees entre ces deux infractions
et entre les deux sanctions qui
procèdent de l'un ou l'autre des
comportements je justement racontez
comment vous avez vécu le début de de
ces de ces émeutes de ces journées
d'émeutes ces journé des nuit d'meut et
puis il y a une sorte d'arrêt presque
brutale vous l'avez senti venir ça on
l'a pas senti venir mais on a on a
compris pourquoi on a compris pourquoi
c'està-dire que ça s'est arrêté parce
que ça perturbait le trafic c'est ça
hein c'est bien ça éidment bien sûr mais
oui mais bien sûr alors ils sont pas
venus me le dire dans mon bureau en
disant bah attendez madame le Maire on
va
arrêter là vraiment le temps d'argent
qu'on a par jour ça ça fonctionne plus
mais c'était ça he c'était ça
c'est-àdire que ceux qui sont venus
faire tout toutes ces problématiques et
bien étai très très jeunes faut quand
même le savoir hein c'était entre 13 et
17 ans donc mais par contre les aînés
qui G un petit peu tout ce trafic faut
quand même appeler un chat un chat à un
moment donné on dit stop la récrée c'est
terminé et ça s'est vraiment senti ça
s'est fait du jour au lendemain c'est ça
mais est-ce que c'était eux aussi les
initiateurs ou pas
euh alors moi je prends comme exemple
les les les les quelques problématiques
nous avons eu sur les sur la ville et ça
venait effectivement d'agitateur adulte
d'accord donc en ce qui concerne ces
émeutes là sur la ville de plaisir je ne
saurais le dire mais j'aurais tendance à
dire
il y a des chances mais en tout cas sur
d'autres faits il y a eu d'ailleurs ils
ont été reçus et pas incarcérés mais en
tout cas reçu par la police et c'est
vrai que ce sont des agitateurs par
exemple ce qu'on évoquéit tout à l'heure
sur les gestes d'égorgements et tout ça
c'était fait par des personnes qui sont
qui sont des personnes adultes qui font
partie aussi d'une association assez
enfin qui est reconnu malheureusement je
dis malheureusement au niveau national
et qui sont des agitateur de quartier en
politique de la ville et à l'intérieur
desquels il y a même des personnes qui
font qui se servent de quartier pour
faire des thèses par rapport à qu'est-ce
que c'est qu'un quartier en politique de
la ville et qu'est-ce que c'est je vous
assure on en a la preuve et donc ils
viennent dans le quartier ils se serv
ils s'en servent comme agitation pour
voir un petit peu comment ça fonctionne
je le dis parce que j'en ai la preuve et
on l'a vu avec la police avec et et on
peut rien faire contre ces
il y a eu bah il y a eu rencontres
discussions il y a eu certainement je
pense aussi la police des avocats et
tout ça et donc il y a eu pendant
quelques mois une acalmie sur le
quartier parce que les personnes
concernées ont pris un peu peur
peut-être j'imagine et là ça recommence
tout doucement je suis assez étonnée
effectivement que quand on a bien
identifié les personnes et bien il y ait
pas plus d'action tourné vers ces
personneslà actuellement essaye avec les
les associations du quartier de leur
dire mais soyez partenaire avec la ville
votre quartier est en danger parce que
vous avez quelque agitateur essayz
ensemble pourquoi pas de porter plainte
aussi contre ces personnes vous les
connaissez vous les voyez agir sur le
quartier c'est très compliqué vous savez
de la même façon que moi je peux être en
danger il y a la peur il a la peur qui
est tout à fait légitime ouais donc
c'est dans votre dans votre expérience
d'élu et de mer c'est c'est un des
moments les plus terribles que vous avez
vécu euh non non non c'est dire c'est
dire c'est dire oui c'est dire la
difficulté de la fonction non parce que
on doit être enfin je sais pas je j'ai
c'est ce que je disais au Congrès des
mères je j'ai jamais eu l'intention ni
de démissionner ni l lâcher prise mais
euh non le non le pire pour moi c'est de
pas réussir à faire ce que je voudrais
faire sur la collectivité
particulièrement dans ces quartiers là
où je vois
les aides que nous que nous avons même
de l'État l'état apporte énormément
d'argent sur ces quartiers là et on n
pas de résultat vraiment probant et
comme vous le disiez par rapport aux
familles oui et par rapport aux familles
on a vraiment besoin de travailler avec
les familles je dis pas de de de de
mettre en péril les familles mais de
travailler avec les familles pour
pouvoir les sortir de là tout vient de
l'éducation à la base c'est un petit peu
un
raccourci je le vois et je le vis vie ça
vient de l'éducation un enfant de 8 ans
10 ans 12 ans qui est dans la rue à
minuit c'est pas normal c'est peut-être
caricaturel encore une fois mais c'est
pas normal non mais absolument puisquon
parle d'éducation il y a on a vu il y a
eu des atteintes à la laïcité on l'a vu
encore tout récemment bah dans dans les
ivelines lorsque professeur a montré un
un un tableau du 17e siècle et voit des
femmes nues et que les que des des des
des des jeunes élèves ont protesté
onment
on a on a vu plusieurs ates à la à la
lacité il y a eu uneinterdiction de la
BAA par le par le ministre de
l'éducation
nationale on a l'impression justement
avec peut-être gabrielal l'éducation
nationale qu'on prend en compte
maintenant ces fait puis que voilà on
redonne on redonne vie à la laïcité bah
en tout cas oui un ministre qui semble
enfin avoir un discours à peu près clair
sur ce sur ce domaine des des des i bien
carré des prises de parole qui qui
n'attendent pas 15 jours dès le
lendemain de cette sinistre à faire du
du tableau il a pris la parole avec un
discours un discours absolument
remarquable il est venu sur place donc
c'est la seule solution c'est
effectivement là pour une fois on
l'impression qu'il y a quelqu'un qui qui
tient le ministère et qui qui a quelque
chose à dire et un schéma de pensée
structuré et clair et net donc ça bravo
ce qui manque peut-être peut-être
vis-à-vis de parce que j'ai l'autre jour
j'étais dans un un événement qui était
très intéressant avec des jeunes
justement des des des des quartiers
comme ça qui faisaient un concours
d'éloquence et c'était très intéressant
et justement alors il disait oui mais on
peut on peut avoir une croix chrétienne
mais on nous interdit la BAA par exemple
c une des questions qu'il posait et et
j'essaie moi d'expliquer que c'est
l'interdiction de la BAA c'est pas une
mesure pour les embêter aujourd'hui
c'est ça vient d'une vieille tradition
française qui est celle de la la cité
qui qui qu'on peut remonter euh voilà la
révolution à Voltaire la faire Calas et
cetera euh donc c'est peut-être ça aussi
qui manque c'est d'expliquer d'où nous
venons aussi enfin quelles sont les les
valeurs qui nous ont
euh d'expliquer d'où nous venons c'est
d'expliquer qui on est vois
c'est c'est c'est pas la tenue classique
la baaya le le le le le chador et ce non
mais je ça ça n' pas lie d'être c'est
pas c'est pas une humiliation c'est pas
un truc je veux dire c'est une règle
c'est tout oui ben faudrait juste que
les gens entendent la règle et
respectent les règles si si on commençit
à redire aux gens que les lois sont
faites pour être respecté que les règles
sont faites pour être suivies et que
quand on vient dans un pays c'est c'est
qu'on en accepte le la façon de vivre on
en accepte l'histoire on en accepte les
les les us et coutumes la situation
serait quand même extrêmement simple
alors que là on discute de tout il y a
pas à discuter de ça je veux dire si on
a envie de montrer un tableau avec des
femmes nues en classe la loi l'autorise
c'est c'est dans nos nos coutumes c'est
cure c'est l'éducation c'est la culture
il y a même pas de débat il y a pas de
débat que vous êtes pas concerné puisque
la université exp tout le monde peut
venir avec la tenue qu' qu'il veut voilà
mais je je connais un temps où certains
collègues demandaient à ce qu'on enlève
le couvre-chef pour parler largement et
puis ensuite alors on trouvait normal de
dire un étudiant on enlève la casquette
quand on est en cours mais aujourd'hui
on peut plus parce que Al moi je le fais
moi je le fais moi je le fais tout je
m'arrête plus à ces considérations parce
que un Couvrechef c'est un Couvrechef
donc dans ces cas-là pourquoi la
casquette est pas c'est exactement ce
que je dis en début d'année je dis
messieurs vous retirez vos casquettes
vous retirez vos bonnets vous retirez
vos trucs vous pourriez tout à fait me
rétorquer pourquoi est-ce que j'exige
pas que mademoiselle retire son voile
vous vous le faites ou vous le faites
pas on pourra en discuter mais ils le
font pas le casquette compé mais c'est
compliqué parce qu'à l'université il y a
deux il y a deux problèmes enfin
rapidement c'est lors des examens on m'a
demandé de vérifier qu'il n'y avait pas
des écouteurs sous un voile donc ça ça
pose problème parce que déjà un homme ne
peut pas le faire et je ne me suis pas
permis non plus j'ai demandé
l'autorisation c'est l'accep pe-êt de
lever son voile pour qu'on voit ses
oreilles mais voilà c'est je ne sais pas
jusquoù on a le droit d'aller mais en
même temps bon il y a quand même un
règlement d'examen donc on doit être en
mesure de vérifier certaines choses et
puis il y a l'autre chose qui moi je
vais le souvenir d'étudiant en master
qui arrivaient en tenue voilé et qui
allait se changer et qui était en
jogging en croptop mais vraiment voir
les différen hein donc il y a vraiment
un ché bien pourquoi donc on sent bien
que on lui rendrait service peut-être à
lui demander une certaine cohérence avec
le le le ce que l'on porte c'est ce que
pte les jeunes filles de son âge donc là
c'est pas toujours défendre la femme que
de laisser faire pour parler
toutitaustie moi ça m arrivé d'avoir des
étudiants qui m'ont dit ben nous dans le
quartier dans lequel on habite il est
hors de question qu'on soit pas voilé
ici ici il y a pas de problème on peut
le retirer pour pour trouver du boulot
je on peut le retirer mais pour partir
de chez nous non on peut pas sinon on va
on va être traité comme des moins que
rien et Cera donc c'est tout à fait vrai
mais c'est c'est c'est effectivement
tout le combat de du féminisme enfin du
féminisme de bon à loi qui dire c'est
c'est pas service aux femmes que de les
laisser voiler nous avons eu enfin la
profession d'avocat aussi le le sujet
sur des des des alors dans le cadre de
prestation de serment de d'avocats et
aussi d'intervention d' audience des des
jeunes femmes qui arrivaient voilé et
qui qui souhaitaient pouvoir exercer
avec leur voile et alors ça a été source
de nombreux débats parmi les conseils de
l'ordre et parmi les instance de la
profession et finalement il s'est avéré
que non on ne peut pas venir vêtu de son
ABAA ou en excipant un signe
ostentatoire de religion lorsque on
porte une robe d'avocat la robe d'avocat
suffit donc elles ont dû pouvoir prêter
sment enlever leur VO une croix une
grosse croix sur la robe d'avocat par
exemple non non voilà donc ça a été non
non je dis ça parce que ça concerne et
ça a été oui ça a été source aussi
de réflexion intense mais tout ça j'en
viens c'estes problèm de règles parce
que toujours avec ces études avec je
discutais notamment cell qui sont voilés
dit en terminale jusqu'en terminal on a
pas le droit de porter un voile ça ne
pose pas de problème on nous dit pas de
voile on met pas de voile à l'université
on nous dit pouvez mettre un voile on
met un voile je veux dire si si on leur
disait pas de voile il y a beaucoup de
de de mais si mais après on peut
admettre que non on peut admettre que
chacun est l'université non mais avec
vous Patrice on admettrait tout
alors par de C arguments non à partir
d'un certain âge on a le droit de
choisir ce à quoi on cro
à quoi on croit bien sûr mais mais mais
mais mais ce comment on se vait et quand
le quand
la individuelle non mais la liberté
individuelle elle joue aussi elle compte
aussi bah oui ENF bon non mais c'est
c'est le c'est le débat et c'est pour ça
que c'est permis à l'université en
revanche les enseignants eux sontus à
une laïcité très
très pas donner leurs opinions notamment
leurs opinions religieuses un mot je
sais une com sur un sujet qui vous tient
à cœur et et qui est un peu pas tout à
fait li mais un peu li c'est la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
il y a beaucoup de vous avez beaucoup de
choses notamment dans votre ville
notamment une une maison des femmesou
oui de oui un café des femmes mais ils
ont des femmes deux choses différentes
mais très complémentaires oui alors le
café des femmes ça permet de les de les
réunir et de faire des formations avec
remettre dans l'emploi he c'est ça c'est
ça avec le nôtre entre autres et l'uréal
qui les accompagne sur le je dirais bah
retrouver une image voilà ça c'est le
café des femmes et la Maison des Femmes
Calypso ça c'est encore autre chose
c'est encadré par des professionnels de
la médecine avec avec des sages-femmes
des psychologues des et puis aussi de
l'art thérapie c'est une maison qui
aujourd'hui euh va déménager puisqu'on
est dans un local de l'hôpital de
plaisir mais qui va aller aujourd'hui
dans une grande maison prise en charge
par le Département des zivelin j'ai
obten tenue du département et je
remercie encore le président 1007 pour
refaire intégralement cette maison pour
accueillir des femmes qui viennent là en
toute
transparence et et je veux dire liberté
on les on les accueille et elles sont
entendues par des professionnels et je
veux dire tout est traité hein
c'est-à-dire les problèmes de violence
conjugale le viol
l'excision enfin bon bref tout ce qu'on
peut imaginer et en l'espace de 2 ans on
a reçu des centaines de femmes déjà sans
publicité sans rien le bouche à oreille
s fait et elles viennent d'un peu
partout c'est le la première Maison des
Femmes du département des ivelines et
Madame bornne est venue nous voir et a
dit qu'elle voulait en faire un dans
chaque département donc moi j'aurais on
pourrait être fier d'avoir mis ça à
Plaisir moi j'avoue que je suis pas
fière dans le sens où on en a besoin
donc c'est c'est voilà on aimerait qu'il
a pas besoin oui et on a beaucoup de
bénévolat aussi d'art thérapie pour les
accompagner parce qu'elles peuvent
revenir de TR 4 5 fois tant qu'elles en
ont besoin et elles sont encadrées aussi
hormis les professionnels de santé par
des personnes qui leur donnent un peu de
bien-être donc ouiou je suis très
sensible à tous ces sujets là parce que
je su femme mais c'est important très
toujours très difficile à mesurer mais
que que les les ces violences sont en
train de régresser alors c'est vrai
qu'on elles sont aussi mieux connu parce
qu'on il y a plus de dénonciation qu'il
y en avait probablement autrefis donc on
a l'impression que ça monte mais est-ce
que quand même il y a une prise de
conscience ou pas ou c'est encore long
euh je moi je c'est vrai que la parole
est plus peut-être un peu plus simple je
dis un peu plus simple parce qu' a des
femmes qui ne parlent pas il a des
femmes qui viennent dans mon bureau m'en
parler à moi qui ne feront pas la
démarche d'y alleraller oui et c'est
tout mais mais ce qui est ce qui est
vrai c'est que ce qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure sur le changement sociétal des
gens qui sont beaucoup plus accrants
beaucoup plus je dirais dans dans dans
cette énergie assez négative des uns
vis-à-vis des autres moi je crois que
c'est quelque chose qui monte
actuellement c'est pas quelque chose oui
il y a une information qui est beaucoup
plus ouverte mais mais mais je crois que
ça ne se calme pas bien au contraire
bien au contraire oui parce que dans un
situation compliqué ENF complexe de
changement justement il y a des
réactions très fortes et très violentes
oui par Rapp la justice quand vous êtes
dans cette situation là elle les hommes
ou les femmes enfin bref souvent sont
des des hommes qui qui sont violents
plus que des femmes même s'il y en a il
y en a ou là là il y en a je le
sais n'ont pas peur de la justice hein
quand ils sont dans cette situation là
ils sont fiches Royal he je va vous dire
c'est une fois qu'ils sont devant la
police et devant que là mais sur le ou
sur le moment S sont pas en train de ou
là attends je vais pas lui mettre une
baffe parce que sinon je vais me faire
attraper non non c'est pas du tout leur
problème he c'est vraiment quelque chose
de de très
profond qui malheureusement à mon avis
ne se calme pas d'près ce que mon alors
je je pense que là en ce moment on est
vraiment dans cette phase où les choses
ne s'améliorent pas parce que on voit en
réalité mais effectivement parce que la
parole se libère parce qu'on judiciarise
et c'est heureux beaucoup plus ce type
de comportement on voit qu'on est plutôt
dans un phénomène d'augmentation en tout
cas dans la quantification on est dans
un phénomène d'augmentation il faut je
pense laisser un petit peu le temps que
la justice ou en tout cas que les
sanctions judiciaires qui découlent de
ces comportements la faç son œuvre et je
pense qu'on mesurera une décru dans
quelques années où on verra qu'en
réalité euh effectivement il y a eu une
une action judiciaire il y a eu des
sanctions qui ont été prises et que sans
doute que les personnes qui commettaient
à genre ce genre de fait ou les ou les
enfants qui ont pu être exposés à ce
genre de fait pourront un petit peu
réfléchir en disant bon je ne peux pas
le faire ou le refaire parce que là je
sais que si jamais j'ai ce comportement
là assurément il y aura la justice qui
passera donc là on est effectivement
plus dans un phénomène d'augmentation
euh fort heureusement moi je trouve que
votre votre action et je vous le dis
sans flagornerie est absolument
remarquable puisque il faut
effectivement dans le cadre de violences
faites aux femmes qu'on puisse les
accompagner sur beaucoup d'aspects
l'aspect professionnel l'aspect
sociologique l'aspect psychologique ce
que la justice ne pouvait pas faire
puisque elle elle ne les accompagne que
sur le plan judiciaire et encore pas
toujours
parfaitement et donc je pense qu'on
mesurera dans quelques
années lorsque les choses auront été
vraiment instituées à un phénomène de
décr
çause un pe peu je alors peut-être
suisje un pe peuop optimiste mais je
pense que vraiment on verra à un moment
l'effet de toute cette action concernant
les violences qui sont faites aux femmes
je l'espère on va peut-être passer alors
il y a quelques mots quelques noms qui
ont été les plus rechercher sur les sur
les internets com on dit il y a évid
chat GPT oui tout le monde s'est demandé
qu'est-ce que c'était cette intelligence
artificielle il va il va falloir qu'on
s'y habitue non vous en servez non pour
les cours par exemple non non non non
vous avez des collègues qui je ne pense
pas parce que pour l'instant il y a y a
deux il y a deux versions il y a la
version gratuite la version payante et
qui plus plus ét Faé alors je ne sais
pas non plus si les étudiants s'en
servent et les étudiants oui parce que
ça c'est un vrai
problème mais je pense qu'on est capable
quand même de voir quand quand un un
discours est trop formaté enfin d'autant
qu'on leur demande de réfléchir et
d'avoir une une vision de s'impliquer
d'avoir une vision personnelle donc je
pense que euh bon pour définition
basique il y av internet de toute façon
ça changera pas le vrai problème dans
l'enseignement c'est pas ça va pas être
d'interdire parce qu'on pourra pas
interdire ça do être de comment
travailler avec l'intelligence
artificielle c'est ça c'est de bien
savoir utiliser l'outil parce que déjà
internet euh a permis d'avoir tellement
d'informations et on se rend compte
aujourd'hui trop d'information tue
l'information parce que finalement quand
on donne un sujet il passe presque plus
de temps à aller faire une recherche
biblographique voilà qu' qu'à monter le
plan et qu'à réfléchir donc là je pense
qu'il devrait y avoir on devrait
peut-être faire des cours un peu plus
précis sur le l'utilisation l'usage de
ces nouveaux instruments après certains
vous diraient aussi à l'extrême que
finalement celui qui use qui use et qui
utilise chpt avec avec dextérité s'il a
une bonne note bah c'est tant mieux
parce que finalement c'est qu'il a il
s'est utilisé autre fois on aller dans
bibliothèque pour chercher voilà moi ce
que je demande quelque fois c'est qu'il
fasse un devoir en deux parties enfin
une version avec chat GPT et une version
100 100 et il voit bien la différence
aussi donc ça c'est c'est intéressant
parce qu' il voit bien ce que ce que ça
apporte ouais et du coup c'est assez
créatif pour vos discours non alors mon
directeur il y a des élus qui s'en
servent mon directeur du cabinet il est
paniquer avec ça il m'a dit non non non
non je veux pas m'en servir mais je sais
que au niveau de la ville la
communication je donne un exemple précis
hier on travaillait sur la couve du
nouveau mensuel qui va sortir en janvier
et donc on avait un dessin et il
manquait le bas du personnage ils ont
utilisé l'intelligence artificielle ça a
créé les les jambes nickel CR mais euh
personne n'a rien vu et voilà
normalement on doit le préciser quand
même oui on doit le dire vraiment ce
qu'il faut pas oublier c'est que chat
GPT c'est un quelque chose qui nous
vient des États-Unis donc nous nous
arrive de travailler avec chat GPT
notamment juste avant d'envoyer un
bouquin à l'imprimerie on peut on
redonne 15 liges pour voir s'il y a pas
une dernière faute d'orthographe quand
on a un doute et cetera alors pour ça
c'est très bien c'est pour ça qu'on voit
aussi si les étudiants travaillent avec
chat GPT ou pas c'est voir son un devoir
sans faute devoir sans faute c'est
forcément chat GPT donc ça pour moi
c'est c'est unsi mais et mais sinon ce
qu'il y a c'est que chat GPT c'est d'une
mièvrerie et comme nous on fait des
polar quel
fois de chercher quelque chose c'est moi
j'étais céta concernant quoi fois dans
un dialogue il un Truant qui peut
traiter une femme de alors
c'est parce que le chatp chat GPT tu-toi
l'interlocuteur donc il me dit tu n'as
pas le droit de
traiter de ce ce ce terme
extrêmement extrêmement injurieux et C
chose oui suggère autre chose tu tu es
une femme intéressante dis oui ça va
être intéressant ça va être bien comme
le Québécois qui a eu le prix micis je
crois he oui oui il se venteent ou il a
il a ça a été relu justement pour
enlever tout bah oui mais lui lu parce
que il fait ça plus des sensitivity
readers donc ça c'est juste dramatique
quoi en matière en matière juridique
c'est un concurrent quand même alors
une aide d'ailleurs c'est alors selon
moi ça peut être effectivement un
accompagnateur une aide j'en sais rien
puisqueil y a quand même malgré tout je
vous allez dire que je prêche pour ma
paroisse mais peu importe je l'assume
parfaitement je je pense quand même
queil y a un facteur humain qui est très
important dans le cadre dans le cadre du
droit et de la pratique notamment
d'avocat alors ça dépend effectivement
de quoi on parle est-ce qu'on parle
d'une stricte mise en demeure ou est-ce
qu'on parle de d'une intervention orale
dans le cadre d'une matière un peu plus
spécifique comme le droit pénal par
exemple on peut concevoir
qu'effectivement c'est un vrai assistant
dans le cadre de choses assez basique
après lorsque mais c'est un peu
finalement comme sur la question de de
de l'édition l'écriture de livre
lorsquon lorsquon rentre dans des choses
un peu plus il faut personaliser
technique voilà et qui qui nécessite un
petit peu l'intervention de l'humain et
de la sensibilité de l'humain là là chat
GPT montre ses limites mais c'est vrai
que ça peut être un assistant notamment
pour des recherches de jurisprudence
comme ça et quels sont les arrêts avec
quand même extrêmement vous avez déjà
des des instruments oui on a déjà des
instruments qui fonctionnent bien on n
pas attendu que chat GPT Vienne je vous
avoue jeis être parfaitement honnête moi
je n'ai jamais mis le nez sur Chat GPT
jamais alors j'ai j'ai entendu un un
entretien très intéressant avec un type
dont j'ai oublié le nom mais un des
créateurs de l'intelligence artificielle
qui disait arrêtez tous de dire que
l'intelligence artificielle crée quoi
que ce soit l'intelligence artificielle
ne crée rien ne fait que recracher avec
beaucoup plus avec plus ou moins de
talent ce qu'on incé mais il y a pas de
création il y a pas de plus il y a une
nouvelle étape qui va qui va permettre à
l'intelligence artificielle de se
nourrir elle-même lui lui dit que tout
ça
c'est c'est Pipo et que ça sera ça ne
sera toujours que mieux en mieux mais
c'est la réinterprétation de tout ce
qu'on a mis dedans donc alors dans
Comment à l'origine il y a l'homme voilà
dans les personnalités recherchées aussi
sur les internets il y a évidemment
Pierre
Palmade et et c'est vrai qu' alors j'ai
un lien hier le le enfin le le président
de la République a parlé de Gérard de
pardieu et et c'est vrai que je
peut-être qu'on peut faire un lien entre
les deux c'està dire que comment les
considérer est-ce qu'on les considère
comme ce qui leur arrive à eux en disant
bah un peu c'est c'est drtique c'est une
chasse à l'omme comme dit il y a quand
même une différence notable c'est que
Pierre palmad était au volant de la
voiture il était drogué donc il est
coupable en
donc la mite il est présumé pour
l'instant il était au volant il le
reconnait donc voilà on pe on pourra
c'est vrai on peut effectivement lu
opposer la présomption d'innocence mais
là factuellement il a reconnu il a
reconnu les
fait elle s'applique peut-être de
manière plus nuancée que Gérard par lui
les conteste ce que je veux dire par
c'est considérer les fait qui le arrive
du point de vue de ces de ces personnes
qui qui sont des stars et qui sont un
peu déchus soit du point de vue des
victime audelà de ça même c'est vrai
quand quand quand Emmanuel Macron parle
de Gérard paru il considère que de son
point de vue à lui un peu moins
peut-être malheureusement du côté des
femmes heureusement par que au-delà il a
été très brillant Macron là-dessus enfin
le président Macron sur de pardux
d'abord intelligent et courageux ce ce
qui n pas t jour
son son maître M dans dans la vie mais
ça a étit quand même très bien et puis
il faut quand même arriver à distinguer
l'homme de l'artiste je veux dire on est
tous à adorer Céline qui est une crapule
avérée et on adore ces livres et alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
continuer à dire que de par Dieu le plus
grand comédien français depuis depuis la
guerre et parce que il est supposer
cette malcu mais peut-être est-il
Malcuit la justice nous le dira et j'ai
tout à fait foi et conscience la justice
mais arrêtons je veux dire on peut
continuer à adorer Gérard de pardieux
acteur moi Gérard de pardieu n'est pas
mon ami je ne bois pas de bière avec lui
donc peut me chaud de ce qu' ce qu'il a
fait voilà peut peut-être peut-être ce
qu'il faut extraire du discours d'hier
du président Macron c'est que sur ces
domaines là il faut être un peu
précautionneux dans le sens où on est
allé très vite dans le déboulonnage de
la statue de de Jard pardieu peut-être
faut-il laisser laisser le temps
judiciaire se faire ce que vous disiez
Jech c'est un peu les trois étapes qu'on
connait je lche je lâche je lche oui
absolument absolument
absolument et et à la fin bon laissons
la justice faire si la justice détermine
que il est responsable des faits qui lui
sont reprochés pour lesquels il est
misise en examen et bien à ce moment-là
sans doute faudra-t-il enlever la statut
de Sir musé Grévin comme ça a déjà été
ent voilà et la Légion d'Honneur bon
s'il ne l'est pas effectivement le le
fait d'avoir si on enlève tout d'abord
et qu'ensuite on laisse la justice faire
à la fin il ne reste plus rien si vous
voulez une fois que tout est terminé
quandbien même l'innocence est reconnue
si jamais on a tout enlevé bon on ne
réétablit plus il a un exemple alors sur
la la question de la précaution il y a
un exemple qui est récent et qui est
particulièrement criant c'est celui d'éc
Dupont Moretti dont on disait lorsqu'il
a été renvoyé devant la Cour de Justice
de la République il est Mor pour la
politique voilà qu'il devait absolument
parle comme futur possible Premier
ministre donc don on disait qu'il voilà
les choses vont absolument vite et on
est tout le monde criait queil devait
démissionner parce qu'il était renvoyé
devant la CGR il a dit je ne
démissionnerai pas il y aura un procès
si jamais je suis condamné je
démissionnerai si je suis relaxé et bien
on dira que j'ai bien fait de ne pas
démissionner force de constater que il a
bien fait de pas céder à ces sirènes là
et qu'il a bien fait de rester en poste
quel scandale quel scandale ça aurait
été si jamais il avait été renvoyé
devant la CGR qu'il avait démissionné et
infé relaxé mais toujours est-il qu'il
n'aurait plus son poste de ministre de
la Justice force aussi de constater que
l'opinion publique ne comprenait
absolument rien au procès fait à Dupont
Moretti ça joue aussi beaucoup
tout le monde son avis très peu de G un
avis sur est-ce
queontti fa
cel sur l'ffet meut moi c'est ça qui me
dérange
Dér c'estd que tout le monde s'y met et
on est
[Rires]
encoreou c'est ça qui est dérangeant je
dirais parce que finalement ça trouble
et et et ça crée je dirais un un une
nonanalyse de la situation on est dans
un dans une espèce de d'envahissement
d'information de de de tous les côtés où
est-ce que nous on on se positionne et
comment on on réfléchit aujourd'hui
comment réfléchit-on c'est ça qui m' qui
m'interpelle c'est compliqué cet AFF
justement et vous avez raison parce que
en plus tout le monde exprime son point
de vue a fois tout le monde est avocat
tout le monde peut dire le débat est
totalement confisqué parce qu'en fait on
on en vient à dire de par Dieu est un
chic type ou de par Dieu est une ordure
bah le truc est probablement entre les
deux quoi pour terminer parce qu'il n
reste plus beaucoup de
temps on aurait pu parler de de
d'Édouard Philippe et d'alopée l'alopée
est un mot qui est très recherché on se
demande est-ce que c'est grave pas grave
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'il y a du
changement il a géré moi je trouve qu' a
géré cette transformation physique et la
sien de manière remarquable en tout cas
il a évacué il savait très bien on va
être très clair même si personne n'est
Oracle autour de cette table JeanCharles
peut-être oui je pas à plein
temps on se doute qu'il va être candidat
à la présidentielle de 2027 sauf
empêchement bien sûr et pour que
justement ça ça ne vienne pas parasiter
toutes ces chosesl et que les gens ne
soient pas étonnés par cette
transformation physique il a purgé le
débat bien bien en amont et après on lu
reprochera quand même forcément des des
g malintentionnés qui leur procheront ce
ce physique de N de jardin et qui va
pas ça va
êreileile le prix de l'humour politique
très bien géré aussi le prix de l'humour
politique en disant c'est un concours de
beauté oui
contemp donc effectivement je
trouve manière remarquable on va pour
terminer alors assez rapidement
malheureusement mais un peu un peu 2024
quand même alors j'ai relevé un tweet de
de Marc Antoine Jam c'est le numéro 2 ou
3 de de LVMH c'est le fils de de
journaliste dominique Jamet et là voilà
il dit 2024 Macron dissous énorme
bardellaa à matigon la Russie bat
l'Ukraine et envahille la Moldavie
l'Iran la Syrie et le Liban attaque
Israël Donald Trump gagne les élections
aux États-Unis les Pays-Bas sortent de
l'Europe et la prochaine COP se
déroulera en
Azerbaïdjan c'est vrai que c'est la
c'est la vision du pire ça pourrait
arriver la victoire de Trump notamment
la victoire de Trump pour l'instant
enfin un an des élections mais il est
vrai que dans de nombreux sondages enfin
il y a des des des des synthèses de
sondages parce qu'on prend pas un
sondage on essaie de de les regarder de
façon un peu au fil de l'eau en les en
les accumulant euh il a souvent euh
souvent en tête isavid Biden donc il a
il a ses chances après je je ne suis
même pas sûr que le les empêchements
judiciaires ne l'empêchent de parce que
aux États-Unis la réglementation est
Enis on peut lu dire même derrière les
barreaux je qui vient de lu interdire
non non non il lui a pas interdit de se
présenter c'est le le Colorado c'est la
Cour suprême du Colorado qui qui a voté
à quat contre trois donc déjà c'est à
ses fin Colorado
démocrate et apparemment bien sûr il y a
un recours vis-à-vis de la cour de la
Cour suprême des États-Unis donc le le
Colorado a mis sa suspensive jusqu'au
début janvier et de surcroire il
semblerait quand même que dans la
section 3 de l'amendement du 14e
amendement ça ne peut pas s'opposer un
président donc ce qu'on lui reproche ne
peut pas s'opposer un président même
s'il s'agit quand même de des émeutes et
et de quelque chose de dramatique mais
apparemment il pourrait il pourra en
sortir par deux par deux chemins donc je
pense que c'est d'autres étap av essayé
de le faire sans aller au bout là c'est
ça fait la une de tous les jours de
toute façon toutes les matinales on
ouvert là-dessus et on sait que toute
façon il y aura pas mais c'est c'est un
des des risques je dis risqu possibilité
probabilitéibilité demand même on se
demande même si finalement les échéanges
judiciaires de Trump ne le serent
pas dans certain
électorat absolument proch de il y aura
les Jeux Olympiques oui qui sont seront
important dans dans le dans le
département et et à saint-ctin euh on a
appris hier qu'au fond finalement les
les places partaient pas si vite que ça
ou mais c'était sur les Jeux
paralympiques oui sur les jeux
paralmpiqu non ça part très bien sur sur
les jeux classiques c'est c'est c'est
les places pour les Jeux paralympiques
qui partent très domage parce que c'est
des épreuves absolument formidables
vraiment absolument mais là vous êtes
vous êtes confiante ou pas oui confiante
euh ah ben oui
notre territoire donc on est est on est
ravi c'est un cou faut quand même le
dire un cou assz important mais en même
temps on n pas ça tous les jours
donc question
sécuritéssant dans la scne fait appelle
les flottants et les flottants en fait
ce sont les étrons qui arrivent à l'air
libre mais il y a un vrai problème de
flottant je vous assure c'est tout à
fait sérieux dans dans la scène donc les
gens sont un peu mitigés pour à l'idée
de non mais il suffit pas montré que
c'était possible pour mais c'est
possible s'il pleut pas s'il a pas un
égoutû qui qui est crevé et cetera donc
voilà c'est ça va être compliqué un
derni mot jme malheureusement très
rapidement l'inflation c'est la fin ou
c'est ça peut pas être la fin ça ça
ralentit mais on est encore on était le
bon élève en 2023 on est le mauvais de
l'Europe maintenant parce qu'on a 39 en
en indice corrigé et harmonisé pour
l'Europe l'Europe est à 24 en moyenne
donc il est vrai qu'on a un peu de
retard euh la croissance n'est
pasou la hausse des prix ralentit donc
on aura toujours une hausse des prix à
3,5 % un objectif un peu mieux d'ici la
fin du du quinena mais euh l'inflation
il y il y a tous les éléments qui
peuvent l'expliquer c'est la baisse de
pouvoir d'achat c'est est-ce qu'on
augmente suffisamment les salaires on a
augmenté SEP fois le SMIC il y a des a
des des raccourcissements de l'écart
entre les bas salaires et le SMIC donc
là c'est une question c'est le pouvoir
d'achat le pouvoir d'achat soutient la
consommation si ça soutient la
consommation çaadopte la croissance la
croissance alimente de la consommation
donc là on pourrait avoir des
perspectives un peu mieux orientées a
priori c'est quand même pas le cas il
n'y a que le gouvernement qui est
optimiste sur la croissance à 1 et
quelques pour les la convergence des
économistes est plutôt en dessous de 1 %
0,8 donc les perspectives aussi sur le
déficit sur la dette et puis il y a
l'Europe qui a revu les les les
caractéristiques enfin les critères de
Maastrich où la France a pas eu vraiment
trop son Mo à dire et o on va mais là
encore c'est un peu voilà c'est sur le
déficit et son l'engagement à réduire le
déficit alors selon qu'on est dans la
dans la phase correction parce que nous
on est dans le correctif puisqu'on a
déjà eu des procédures de des procédures
de de de déficit excessif et il y a la
phase de de correction il y aura la
phase de prévention c'est là où il peut
y avoir du du bien parce que si on passe
dans la prévention ça voudrait dire
qu'on a fait des efforts rest son sont
confiants et un petit DD de cadeau la
bête du gevud non la bête des Voges la
bête desves c'est beaucoup mieux c'est
beaucoup plusc c'est plus récent c'est
c'est plus moderne c'est plus actuel
c'est quasiment un compte de Noël par ça
se passe dans les vuges il y a de la
neige il y a un beau château il y a des
il y a des veris style Bacara il y a des
des cristalleries et cetera donc c'est
c'est vraiment idéal c'est écrit par
deux personnes dont Daniel qui une une
grande grande F mais oui grand grande
flic voilà et C édition la joignie
absolument et s sans l'inflation nous on
a assumé le coût du papier n pas
augmenté hein 19 € ça a toujours été 19
€ cour bah oui cadeau cadeau c'est merci
merci beaucoup bonne fête à tous et
puis retrou très vite joyeux Noël si
vous voulez
jouxme une publicité qui dit celui qui
dit Noy Jo il sort tout de
suite merci merci
beaucoup
[Musique]